jason schneiderman the men's groomer
what's the best way to maintain my own
beard
well let me show you
a lot of guys don't know how to trim up
their facial hair correctly
you look at my face right and what's
happening is
is your eyes are driven to the gel area
and um i'd like to just get rid of that
and there's a way to do it that's uh
that's correct
and a lot of guys cut the sides up too
high
to create a chin line or a fake chin
line
and that's all bad
basically you can grab your cell phone
and you come straight
at i wish i had a cell phone hold on
give me a second
let me put this tape on
okay so take the cell phone
come straight past your chin right here
to your neck and that's gonna be the
first cut
and then what you're gonna do is you're
gonna turn your head sideways and you
can see
that line continues over this way so
it's
oh my god kidding me yeah serious so
you come straight out your face
with your cell phone and that shows you
where the first cut's going to be
then if you turn your head sideways that
line continues
that's where you continue the haircut
the beard trim right there
then you just come straight down from in
front of your ear and meet that point
so now it's a big l and you definitely
don't want to cut here and that's what
guys do is they cut their jawline
right there and it just looks silly so
you need this corner
so let me show you real quick
all right so i come straight at it
see that so that's that first line
then i imagine there's a cell phone
there and i just cut it straight across
that way
keeping that corner so it's a straight
line cell phones here cell phones there
and what it does is it actually creates
a little u
[Music]
all right so now we got that straight
line and you don't have it cut up there
then you just follow up right here and
come straight down to that line
and just barely round that corner a
little bit
straight down from here
barely around that corner a little bit
and so if you look at me now i'm not
focusing
right at the the under jowls i'm
focusing at my chin
and then what i do is you can take this
pure gel
by gillette put a little shaving cream
underneath there
and a little up there because these
spots can get cleaned up too
a little pure gel right here right there
right there and then under this neck
hair
and then i got this gillette skin guard
which uh
helps with razor burn and for sensitive
skin it works really good i love this
one
and you can just shave the stuff right
underneath that line you set
and then what happens is
you didn't put your
your beard you still have that nice
strong
squared look to grow the beard out and
then right here
just clean up those bits
on your cheek and you keep that real
soft
you don't need to do a sharp line and
just keep it
natural the other thing that this uh
skin guard
razor has is it has like this little
clipper on the back side so you're
shaving like this you turn it around
and you can set a little line on the
other side it's really a cool feature
and clean up one of those and work on
setting that line with this thing
how does it look guys did i do all right
see that so now we're cleaned up we
don't look like castaway
you know we're not tom hanks so that's
kind of
what i've been working on in the shop to
get people's beers to that perfect
length and then what happens is this
beard will fill in here
and we'll have a nice strong strong chin
line where the other ones are just kind
of
weird when you turn sideways and it
looks like you got the old
chin strap